this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart my bookie and policy
genius
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com
ryan sickler on all your social medias
uh i want to say thank you to you guys
seriously this community continues to
grow
i absolutely love my job and this show
and the stories that people are bringing
here the fact that you can laugh at your
trauma
be that strong about it be that open
about it be that vulnerable about it
i [ __ ] love it thank you for the
messages all that stuff
make sure you're subscribed to the
youtube channel uh
and if you want more of it man hit up
the patreon that community's grown as
well it's called the honeydew with y'all
where i'm highlighting the low lights
with y'all it's five bucks a month if
you sign up for a year
you're getting over a month of free
episodes all right if you or someone you
know has that story that needs to be
heard submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com hopefully we'll get to do
a story with you all right now um i want
to say
talk to you about something real quick
that i'm very proud of you know i record
here at the santa monica music center
and uh working on an uh with a
non-profit here with lana
called outreach through the arts otta
which is at-risk uh youth
uh like myself and the guest you're
about to see where we were kids if we
had a program like this we'd have been
so much further ahead in life i will
tell you that but we're teaching these
kids
how to podcast how to live switch how to
work with cameras
graphics editing the whole thing ash is
over there helping them they're watching
him they're learning and they're super
stoked about it we're going to start a
podcast with these kids
and uh get back so uh very excited about
it keep an eye out for that i'll be
feeding you some of that stuff
you'll probably meet these kids i'm
gonna have them on the patreon they're
really good kids 18 years old with
stories already that are insane so
that's the biz
uh we're highlighting the low lights
over here
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and there's only one
storyteller like this guy he is back
y'all the saga continues
ladies and gentlemen joey diaz all right
i'm just so stoked to talk to you dude i
miss you so much
there was there were those programs when
i was growing up we just robbed them
dog i robbed the science department i
had all the triple beam scales
and they knew it was us they came to us
and they're like just
just give us like eight back you keep
that we robbed all these
eight of them they negotiated with you
we we took all the frogs you know the
frogs
for a month they couldn't dissect the
frog i forgot who i was talking to for a
second
[Laughter]
then we robbed the athletic department
one night what did you take from them
everything that was in that thing from
sneakers to jackets to hoodies
they came to my house the next day and
they're like listen this high school
or what yeah the high school they came
to your house
and they're like we know just come on
give us a break
the kids can't run track this week
without the sneakers
just bring it back
and we'll make balloons leave like we
don't know nothing happened
you know it's like nothing ever happened
i swear to god
i believe you know the government i mean
i believe you
jackets trophies trophies it's taking
trophy you can't even sell those
it didn't um
please before we get into uh the
continuing story here of your life
plug promote everything you want to
i'm at vinnie's the whole month of march
down the shore
vinnie's uh uncle vinnie's comedy club
and point pleasant wednesday nights
eight o'clock twenty dollars working out
with uncle joey
byob byog
too because it's legal to bring grass
now yeah that's right it is huh
so you can actually um they'll let you
smoke at the venue not inside but
outside
no no no no no no smoke outside now it's
illegal in new jersey okay good
um
doing well i love it really got me out
of a funk if it wasn't for patreon
i still would have been in the funk
talking to those people every day and
answered messages you know i had it july
august september and it really gave me a
lot of
confidence like to start at that level
just shooting little videos
and i'd give them two free podcasts a
week just 20 minute podcast just
quick [ __ ] you know yeah i just do i do
an hour i do an hour once a week
and um they're they're great man they're
the die hard so
what how much is yours a month joey
three five and ten three five and ten
and it's
no more no more merchandise no bad [ __ ]
[ __ ] gets lost people don't get the
t-shirts
it's just a pain he has it's just
content
and like you and like jimmy you know i'm
doing the same with my patreon money
i'm helping out a few comics a
couple retired cops i use cops to give
me rides
to the gigs and they're retired you know
[ __ ] like that i donated to the
restaurant thing
yeah support me now i'll donate the
jimmies
that's what my patreon is for help out a
few people i paid mike
you know yeah but you're doing it twice
a week
and 20-minute episodes twice a week yeah
that's great
it's it's more music-based you know [ __ ]
like that well make sure you subscribe
to that and uh yeah what you're
referring to
so uh john minodakis at jimmy's famous
seafood in baltimore took a
page out of portnoy's book and did what
dave did
in baltimore raise money for local uh
restaurants and stuff because they shut
the city down but they didn't shut the
county down
that [ __ ] so he raised over half a
million
and uh today i get to make a call to a
bar
i used to go to back in the day called
ale mary's to let them know that
they're about to receive some money to
help save their business so i'm stoked
on doing that i love i love everybody
out there helping
you know me too you're gonna rely on it
you ain't relying on the government i
know you're relying on the people man
the people
in the beginning i go listen guys i know
they're going to promise you
unemployment
who knows how many people are going to
call go get a job for now go
go stock shelves until this clears up
and sure enough people in jersey are
hurting from unemployment
you know i had a help of a few of my
buddies out last month and this month
because you know it's just a nightmare
what's going on my buddy uh
james took a job at costco you know he
just he's like look i i'm out of work i
need to get a job and took a job as a
you know he's a
he's a dad down there and i said hey
good for you man good for you
you know you can't eat pride that's
right brother pride don't fill your
belly
um all right so let's get back into it
here we're talking
january 1993 is where we left off i
believe you're leaving
colorado i'm leaving colorado i'm
i'm i'm beat up emotionally
i'm beat up mentally you know physically
i wasn't beat up
but just emotionally and mentally
for the first time and um
for the first time in 10 years i was
done again
like i had just gone through a big chunk
of life you know
a lot had happened and i was ready to
move on and
joey sorry just as a reset how old are
you in january of 93
whatever divide take away 58 from 93.
i'll have my calculator i don't have my
calculator with me
yeah what year were you born what year
were you born
i'm 30 years old you're still you're
very young
still you're still young you're in your
20s 29 i got nothing going on
i got comedy under my belt you know i'm
not
featuring yet how long have you been
doing stand up
at that point a year and a half okay you
about me i didn't start
i dabbled at 20 but i didn't do it again
till i was 27 when i really got into it
i was i was doing it every week i was a
host i had me
i was friends with stan hope already and
that type of [ __ ]
and then um i got fired from the broker
where i worked as a dorm uh uh house mc
and i just really went into the dumps
the girl i was dating
moved to new york and i was making
money selling valium that's how i made a
living
selling and eating valium when you're a
valium salesman
depression is definitely going to be in
your life i was going to say
something valuable salesman you just
said
valium salesman sound like you sold it
with a [ __ ] suit and tie
off i was selling valium from like
september of 92
to january 93. that's how i made a
living
and what kind of living what kind of
living we talking are you is that the
only thing you have to do to get by
that's it
sell value five six five six hundred a
week
okay you know that was one of my many
hustles selling valium
i was working for a sports betting
service i delivered chinese food i
delivered coke while i delivered chinese
food
as a cover wait you know how all right
so wait right if i
want to buy coke from you when i order
chinese food
do i ask for a special something
like is there a duck sauce on the side
or
i got the job done i told people if you
need coke call me
so they would call the chinese
restaurant and then one day the chinese
people came up to me they're like we
don't know what go on
you get more calls than we get so i had
to tell the people listen
when you call for a [ __ ] coke you
better order an egg roll or soup
or something so i have an excuse to go
to your house
wait they were just calling asking for
you to come over without making any
orders
yeah that's stupid and the chinese
people are like what the [ __ ]
you get more called than us so i told
people you got to order a pint of fried
rice
and i'll put it in the bottom i'll put
in a baggie in the bottom
so even if i get arrested i can blame it
on a chinese guy
at the restaurant oh i had to download
[ __ ] science
i headed down to a [ __ ] science right
so
i'm doing everything i can if you
if you want if you want if you want to
buy
coke or values from me and i was working
i would actually make you come down to
the venue
the broker i would just tell you
come to the broker and you go why am i
meeting you at the broker and i go
because i
i got to meet my colombian friend there
you don't want you want your coke
pure right you go yeah i go yes i'll
meet me at the broker
i'll give it to you after broker no you
were going to pay for a ticket to come
to the comedy show
so i was making you okay all right so
you got to [ __ ]
broken me
i'm on the stage going hey come on come
on babe
just pay the five at the door and the
people would pay and
take care of him afterwards and they go
what about the ten dollars i paid at the
door
and i'd make up some story give him an
extra pill i think i was paying like a
quarter of a pill
and i was selling them for like three
bucks
damn so it was like it was like high
profit i was getting rid of three 400 a
week
you know so i found myself
just broken i was broken about how my
divorce was going
i was broken about the only thing that
was good in my life was comedy
that was the only good thing in my life
but you're taking those volumes so
you're bringing yourself down
medically too so
there with a pill watching tv like some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i'm doing coke and then i'm
eating the valium to throw off the
[ __ ] coke so i get a heart out
so i had a little asian girlfriend at
the time we were having a little affair
and i just we weren't going nowhere it
just was a dead life
so i [ __ ] called a friend of mine
his wife answered and i told her what
was going on in my life
and she sent me a plane ticket to come
home
i went i got like a thousand volumes
because i knew i could get rid of them
here
and i [ __ ] just came here like super
bowl sunday 93
and i sold some valiums and
i got a job selling cars
and i started doing comedy around the
city at the new york comedy club and
stuff like that
so you left colorado to go to did you go
to new york or back to jersey
i went to jersey and then you would do
comedy at night
in new york city i was selling cars you
know and then finally
she had a baby where i was staying she
was pregnant
and they had a baby so i had to find a
place to stay
so my buddy had to go to rehab
so his mother let me stay at his house
while he was in rehab
with the deal that when he got out of
rehab i was going to take care of him
i was in no position to take care of
anybody out of rehabs
i had my own rehab issues but i was a
functioning you know what i'm saying
like i was so i was working in the city
i stayed in new york from january of 93
to november of 93. i probably got on
stage 12 times
in those months not as many as i should
you know it was a hard time for me
i i was watching a lot of comedy
you know like when you're at that level
that nobody will talk to you at a comedy
club you just go there
they know you're a comic kind of you did
an open mic there and you ate a bag of
[ __ ]
yeah they don't really they don't really
talk to you and you don't talk to them
like i was at that level so i was going
into like uh
lucian's club and stuff like that and
watch
and then at night i would go to an open
mic that started at 11.
it went from 11 to 4. damn
four in the morning and sign up was at
11. and when you got there you were
already in the number 94.
holy [ __ ] yeah it was like six minute
spot
it was called yay old triple
so i would sign up and i would drive a
limo
and i would go to kennedy airport pick
up the last asian because japanese
people usually fly in late about one
i'd pick them up i'd drive them drop
them off and then i go to yo
triple n and my spot would be ready
it'd be like 2 30 in the morning i'd be
like half hour away from doing my spot
i remember being on stage and seeing a
chick giving a guy a hand job at the
audience
like that's the type of place it was
like you know
so i've always wanted to do stand-up
like at one of those old blues brothers
places where they put the cage fence up
and people go through
people could throw [ __ ] i've always
wanted to do that this
this was the place without the cage it
sounds like
let me ask you this question real quick
you're going through what you're going
through you're in a dark place
what is that six minutes doing for you
um when you're getting on stage and at
least getting to [ __ ] tell these
jokes
does that six minutes helping you more
than than any drug
or you know how are you feeling yeah
yeah because you want to keep going back
right
i was really at an all-time low
human being the only thing that was
keeping me alive was my day job
you know i liked my day job i got a job
working for a dear friend of mine who
owned the sandwich place and he wanted
to start a delivery business
so i would take go to all the businesses
in the area
take the phone number and i would fax
them the menu for the day
and i tripled his delivery business
so i would work from 10 30 to 1
2 o'clock and make about 800 a week
there
and then i'd either drive a limo in the
afternoon
four o'clock to 12. and that was it that
was my
my thing i was also going into the city
for drugs for people
people didn't like going into new york
city to buy coke
so i i charged you a fee so grams of
coke with 35 hours i tried you're 45.
you know so you pick up and deliver
yeah i'd pick up i'd walk over the
bridge in those days
really i used to walk over to georgia
yeah because george washington bridge
you could walk over yeah back then can
you still now can you walk that bridge
yeah oh you can
i don't know i don't know if i'm in the
shape to do it now it's going to be a
long walk
but but back in 93 i used to do it back
and forth in you know an hour and a half
cop stop eat some cuban food on the
other side
so my roommate had gotten out of rehab
and he's my best friend we're still best
best friends
we talk every day okay his daughter his
daughter works for me on patreon
oh nice all right um he went to rehab
so it was me him and his grandmother
living in a two-bedroom apartment
in cliffside park new jersey so when he
got out of the rehab he was hooked on
heroin
so it was like a joint fam he has a
great family
so his grandmother his mother his sister
and his aunt were like his support
system
and me you know but it was me and his
grandmother
who lived there with him right so every
night
you know he didn't have a job he was on
disability
he they got him a job in the city like
moving rocks in the daytime
he got paid like with food stamps like
once a week
and he'd go buy heroin with it
i love that heroin dealers will take
food stamps
there's an [ __ ] heroin dealer taking
bitcoin and [ __ ] today you know that
guy's out there
so so george
would sit there at night we'd be
watching tv
and he couldn't wait for his grandmother
to go to bed that was our whole goal
you know like like if i walked into 12
and grandma was awake
george's face was bred because he was
dying to shoot
but he couldn't because his grandmother
was awake
so so i'd come in i'd go grandma
what are you doing up letterman's on go
watch david letterman
and he look at me like thank god and
then he'd go and
she'd go in her room close the door and
she had a cat
she had a cat out of her room on her on
her bed and she would just sit there at
night
snacking like eating popcorn and i would
wait
for george to go in the bathroom and i'd
time it perfectly
you know i let him burn it let him put
the [ __ ] thing on
and then i'd shoot spitballs at him
to her
through the door
she would sit there with the cat and all
of a sudden these spitballs would be
hitting the bandage
she'd be looking up at the ceiling
because she thought the stuff was coming
off the ceiling
and she'd go what the hell and she'd get
up and she'd go looking for her grandson
georgie what and didn't i be in the room
laying there
like making believe i was just yeah yeah
and she come in and she'd go
georgie and i go grandma it's me and she
goes where's judge i go i don't know
and she knew he was shooting heroin in
the bathroom so she would
she would start she would stole him from
the bathroom and bang on the door
if he's all tied off and [ __ ]
he's over there looking like marilyn
manson all tied up and [ __ ]
so the other one i used to do to him
you know they were art they were their
families an art collector they're art
collectors
and they had this big gong
in the hallway and again there were some
nights
that grandma would go to bed
i would lay down but george would go to
bed first
he would play it off like you know what
grandma i'm tired
he would go to bed sweating bullets
because he knew if he went to bed
grandma would go to bed because she
wouldn't have to worry about him
so again i'd let him go to bed
grandma go to bed and then i'd go to bed
and sure enough george would get up
give him enough time to cook the heroin
and tie up his arm
and then i'd walk out into the hallway
with a hammer
i know those gongs i've hit one of those
before that [ __ ] thing
is like it made my daughter cry
they're loud as [ __ ] man i
i hit the gong and again she'd come out
[ __ ] with georgie i don't know and she'd
run into the bathroom
georgie open up and she'd bang on the
door the whole [ __ ] thing
i'll never forget he used it was like i
was
my life like i was physically and
mentally down
but my house was [ __ ] hilarious
he used to sit on the couch and flick
his ashes behind the couch and i
remember one day grandma caught him
and she moved the couch and it was just
a mountain of ashes
like like do you know how many ashes it
has to be
to be a mouth yeah like there was ashes
on top of cigarettes
he was just throwing cigarettes back
there and ashes
it was just it was just a [ __ ] uh
it was a horror show i had to be in the
city
some days i had a free ride into new
york
because my friend's father was a bus
driver so i had to learn his schedule
and let you get on for free yeah that's
nice his son
his son is that is dead now but he was
alive then
and it was just my education into comedy
it was
those nine months in new york
like it was a lot of fun uh
i did a couple crimes i can't talk about
it all right
okay all right like like
ripping off drug dealers yeah i had a
friend that was still into it and uh
let me let me ask you this all the
crimes that you've committed in your
life
from kidnapping to dealing to whatever
what was the one that was most
nerve-racking would it be
would it be the kidnapping or would it
be knocking off a dealer because i feel
like knocking off a dealer is
dangerous not knocking off a beat and
that's what i was doing
my buddy had gotten dea badges
he was getting info he was getting
he he was getting his info
from a dea agent
and it was like stealing
and so you guys could just go make those
hits
yeah on tuesday he's gonna get a
delivery at his office
of a kilo and he's got two guys that
bring four guys
then bring four guys with guns you know
so i did that like two or three times
and i was like i'm out of that business
yeah i mean doesn't that just [ __ ]
aren't you i'm always looking over your
shoulder then
i'm i'm a [ __ ] comedian i'm done yeah
and then like august of 93 i was like
what the [ __ ] am i doing with my life i
had a daughter back in boulder
you know this comedy thing
i just came and looked behind i looked
into the mouth of the tiger
this requires a lot of work it's going
to be a lot
i could stay here and work really hard
or go to colorado be closer to my
daughter
and work and do better work
like i don't have to do bringing shows
like i knew people who book shows every
week at bars
and stuff like that and it was crazy i
got a
i quit the job at the deli
and like the end of the summer and i got
a job
selling uh nissans and lincolns or
something like that
mazda's god damn and in englewood
cliffs it's a high-end area
and one day this girl came in with this
guy a [ __ ] beautiful girl
puerto rican girl just a 12.
body wise was a 12 and this kid's just a
little mook
you know and as i saw in the car they
just graduated college she's a drug
counselor
he's like studying to be like a half a
[ __ ] i
don't know what the [ __ ] he's bloody in
the beat
she she was beautiful you know
and i called her two days later to see
how the car was going
as a salesman you always have to call
and see how the car is doing it is there
anything else i can do for you
conversation you know and she goes i
want to come see you do stand up and
i suck and uh she came by herself
and i go where's your boyfriend and she
goes my me and him broke up
after three years we decided it was time
so i started dating her under the
the lie that i was clean and sober
oh yeah she's a drug counselor yeah she
was a drug counselor
but the car she bought from me she was
buying because she wanted to drive to
colorado
no way she got a job offer in denver
so i said listen you're still going to
denver and she goes yeah i go i'll make
the ride with you
it was like perfect it was like she came
in bought the car
and a month later we
had to make a move you know she's like
i'm i'm think i'm leaving like
mid-october or something like that and
i'll never forget that
i had no money put away like i had
nothing
my money went to an attorney child
support
and my drug habit i think i paid
george's mom like
15 bucks a week to live there in the
bedroom you know and
that was it everything else went to my
nose
an attorney built and child support
so i had to rob one more drug dealer
before you split
yeah and that one was really scary why
you know what can you say about it
like when you're robbing them are they
there or you hitting their stash when
they're
not there are you taking it from them
like how's it going now
they're there they're there do they know
who you are
are you covered no no i don't know okay
no we'll cover them i don't know them
i don't know what their patterns are i
don't know you know
so that's the scary thing yeah so i
needed money
i needed quick cash and i remember
we busted in there it was the weirdest
thing
because this is how weird life is
i would work if i didn't work at the
deli
if i worked at the deli i would meet
this certain kid
and he would take his car he would rent
like a car
that resembled the cop car and he would
park three or four blocks
from their stash house and he wanted
them to see him
right because in their mind
we wanted them to think we were cops
so when you come in and your cops what
are you going to say just take
everything
go to restless so we were going to guys
as being cops you know like
you know this one time it wasn't good
the one guy was like you're not a cop
really he called it out
and i yeah and i was like that's it i'm
not doing this again we had to run a
little bit like i had to
run like a block or two you ever get
shot at or anything like that
no no no not this time but then
like that money
took like 30 percent loan of what
i owed like i still wasn't right i still
i didn't have enough money to move
you know i was [ __ ] broke i was
living
hand to mouth and uh he called me up
again
and he goes i got a new line and a guy
so this guy we followed
when we followed him for about four days
and do you know this was the easiest
money i ever made we were following him
on the henry
hudson parkway expressway
we were like by a hundredth street 110th
street
and there's like a pull-off section he
just pulled off and ran away from the
car
oh cause he thought you guys were cops
following them
that is easy as [ __ ] we drove around i
take the car
too i take it off we opened up the trunk
it was right there in the trunk four
pounds we took it
and that's how i made the money and then
i put a bet in
on philadelphia was playing the jets i
think
in jersey and randall cunningham got
hurt
and i covered the bet like the bet won i
won like another eight thousand dollars
or something it was like
like i already had money and i put this
huge bet in
and the deal was if i won i would
collect and if i lose
i was going to colorado anyway right
i'm saying i ended up winning so that
gave me more money to take to colorado
so i think i left the colorado
maybe like a week before halloween
now i've done that drive from maryland
so
if you're doing coke and pills and all
this how are you hiding that on a
cross-country trip with a drug counselor
well with her i would i just took a
little bit of coke with me
and uh i had weed
joints rolled you know with banaca
and you know the whole [ __ ] visine
and stuff i would smoke
in the mornings while she was taking a
shower in the hotel room
and go for a walk and air out and [ __ ]
like that you know
and then uh we got to denver
you know i got to see my daughter we got
an apartment
like an aurora a suburb of denver
she started her job i think i lasted 10
days in the house
and she caught me she did yeah
and she goes i had a feeling you smell
like marijuana 10 days ago
why didn't you just tell me the truth
and all this [ __ ]
i'm like i don't know you were just so
[ __ ] hot
you know she didn't go for it she said
she couldn't
that her job she would lose her job you
know
so uh i ended up moving him with a
cousin of mine
who was [ __ ] nuts you know
uh he wasn't a blood cousin but we had
grown up together
and i had seeked him out
uh he got me a job i worked with him for
like a month or two selling cars
and then the weirdest thing a girl came
into my life
now i'm looking at my daughter i'm
seeing my daughter now
the whole thing but this girl came into
my life lori
her name was really pretty i knew her
for years
i knew her husband i knew everybody all
of a sudden when i get back
in that time her and her husband broke
up
and she had just gone off the rails she
was [ __ ] doing blow every night the
whole [ __ ] deal
so me and her got a hotel room and lived
together for about a month
and we were just like cocaine partners
we slept together a few times
stuff like that but we were more friends
than anything
and one day i bumped into a husband who
was a great guy
he put his hand out and he goes can i
talk to you about something i go what's
up
and he goes listen man i really want to
get back together with my wife
would you mind would you just give us
if you left her alone he didn't threaten
me or anything
he this guy could probably beat me up
but he was a man you know
he goes you could do what you want but
if you could help me i have a child with
her
and if i could get her sober the child
could have a mother again
you know so i remember i thought about
it and i'm like this guy came up to me
like a [ __ ] man
you know so i stopped seeing her
i just got my stuff and left she was
pissed she called me a bunch of names
and i found a little apartment in
boulder right before the holidays
and uh
yeah i started 94 in boulder
it's agenda and it was great january 94
by that time i'm rocking and rolling in
comedy and boulder
you are and what are you doing uh to pay
bills and things are you still do you
still have a job are you hustling what
are you doing
i'm doing a couple different things i'm
[ __ ]
uh selling cars i'm selling neon
at the time i was doing whatever i could
i mean
like those lights and [ __ ] that used to
be on everything yeah
open signs and all that [ __ ] oh okay
like that
and uh
i was just doing comedy comedy was my
life
comedy was my [ __ ] life you know so
hold on here
[Applause]
yeah can we keep this in
yeah you can
uh it was a whole different kind of sit
down right here
there's a whole different kind of sit
down
when you have uh when you have you know
i'm
tapering off the pain pose
so i gotta eat these other pills
that slice through your stomach i drink
three drink
probiotic drinks a day you know
and but i take this pill
that's a pharmaceutical to really break
things up in your [ __ ]
and when you got a [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
jack
there ain't no time they know nothing a
couple weeks ago i was doing a
couple weeks ago i was doing a podcast
and i had a [ __ ]
and i had to come in here with the
camera and everything and just like
nothing happened
there was one it was an audio one for
patreon
people were hearing the people put
comments we heard you flush
[Laughter]
dude i've been there before i've been
there where i go to fart and i feel
i'm like no no talking to myself like no
i don't have the
outfit for this it's horrible it's
horrible to have to [ __ ]
do a podcast not to take a [ __ ] or a
piss in the middle of it
in the middle of this whole uh surgery i
had to take a a
little bottle with me into the podcast
room um
and sometimes while i was doing the
podcast i'd have to take my little dick
out
and pee in the bottle because i have a
stocking on it's taking all the fluids
out of my leg
so i gotta pee every [ __ ] 15 [ __ ]
minutes
oh man tremendous tremendous is right
this is a real podcast this is how
podcasting used to be we'd all do
our apartments all these [ __ ] well
your studio the lighting isn't right
yeah go [ __ ] yourself
don't you love those guys they complain
about the lighting
like we the sound you know once it's
going to go
how's the sound when you suck a dick on
the street how's that
sound your [ __ ] [ __ ] sack of [ __ ]
anyway sorry about that it's a
tremendous [ __ ]
it's coming out nice and smooth good as
you can see there's no pressure
no i see these little faces
nah nice and smooth that's his
medication
it's not even a stool softener it's a
mist
yeah i know those [ __ ] uh those pills
are
clogging all up so this this this
cleans you out ah and there's no it's
right when it's not it's now
right now it's now there's nothing
there's no hold on
i gotta wait i gotta do two things and
i got some manscape cologne right here i
could sprinkle some of my
on my ass right after this you know what
i'm saying
a little right there in the muffler
nobody gets their feelings hurt
you know me i don't have a i don't like
putting my toilet paper on a thing
i got to do it [ __ ] right here
and that's it that's how we do it
i'm gonna sit here and call a timeout
like some fruitcake oh my god
keep talking i'm wiping i'm ready so uh
we're what are we january 94
pretty much now yeah january 94.
here's the beautiful thing you're not
you're not even remotely
close to the first person i've ever
talked taking a [ __ ] but definitely the
first i've ever talked about podcasting
unless i didn't know unless they had a
bucket under him or something oh my god
thank god my hemorrhoid's gone you know
what i'm saying i had this little
hemorrhoid when i got here
and one day before the surgery i went to
float in the tank you know it's salty
water
that [ __ ] salt got that hemorrhoid
oh my god i think about that i had to
run out of that [ __ ]
thing and getting i had to bend over in
the shower and spread my cheeks
like a gay girl
oh my god
all right so january 94. hold on i gotta
pee hold on all right turn the camera
turn now you don't wanna oh
wait you're gonna stand up to pee now
yeah i don't pee sitting down like a
[ __ ] crew hold on a minute
you're already sitting there why would
you stand up to pee when you're already
sitting there
because i don't like putting my dick in
the toilet because i don't know who else
put that
wait you just took a [ __ ] and you're
standing up to pee
now yeah i want to know if anybody out
there
does that i why you already did all the
work you're sitting there man you just
piss it out
yeah so what am i gonna do put my dick
in the toilet that's dirty
or the piss other dicks have hit it now
you do a little manscaping while you're
here yeah clean it up a little bit
unbelievable throw some pubic hands on
you and there you go
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh man this is this is manscape's new
cologne
[ __ ] refined we're fine i'll spray
some for the [ __ ] man in there
take care that's it
all right get comfy
sorry about that no no worries but when
you gotta go you gotta go
especially if you're on that medication
oh that was a tremendous [ __ ] it had to
be like 19 inches
oh yeah it looks like they look like
three voodoo sticks sticking out of the
[ __ ] part
[ __ ] tremendous i've never heard that
one in my life
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor upstart now
you know that credit card uh that you're
afraid to look at to see what the
balance is well if you've been avoiding
your debt
it's time to confront it upstart can
help you face it and finally pay
it off listen to me upstart is the fast
and easy way to get a personal loan to
pay off your debt it's all online
and whether you're paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people
have used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment upstart find smarter
rates with trusted partners because they
assess
more than just your credit score with
the five minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
from one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars you can get
approved the same day and receive funds
as fast
as one business day if debt is taking
over your life
it's time to get a fresh start with
upstart so many of you have hit me up
and told me that you've used upstart and
how easy it is and how
glad you are that you did it i'm telling
you it's the best thing to do
consolidate it get yourself one monthly
payment all right this is all you have
to do
if you want to find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today
that's upstart.com honeydew don't forget
to use our url to let them know we sent
you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit your income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com honeydew our next
sponsor
is my bookie now march is here i'm a
pisces big fan of march
matter of fact it's my birthday today if
you're listening to this
and march madness has officially begun
it's time for you to shoot your shot and
score big on the non-stop action with my
bookies select the winners
from 63 tournament games in the my
bookie bracket contest for a chance
at ten thousand dollars in cash prizes
and it's only
a buck to enter that's right one dollar
it doesn't matter whether you're filling
out multiple brackets
if you're betting the national
championship winner or if you're simply
looking
for player and game props my bookie has
you covered
sign up today at mybookie.ag and use
promo code honeydew to secure a deposit
bonus up to 1
000 that's promo code honeydew to claim
your first deposit bonus
college ball nba nhl no matter the sport
no matter the minute from tip
off to buzzer my bookie puts the action
in your hands
with in-game live betting bet anything
anytime anywhere with my bookie
our next sponsor is policy genius now if
you're like me during the pandemic i'm
going back looking at all my bills
figuring out what i could pay cheaper
on almost every single thing i'm paying
on so why not get a head start
by revisiting your home and auto
insurance with policy genius
first head to policygenius.com and
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property then
policy genius is going to take it from
there they're going to compare rates
from over america's top insurance
from aggressive to allstate to find your
lowest quotes the policy genius team
will look at all the ways
to maximize your savings including
bundling your home and auto policies
if policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're paying right now
they'll switch you over for free
that kind of services earn policy genius
a five-star rating on thousands of
reviews
on trustpilot and google all right so
while you're gearing up for spring
cleaning don't forget to dust off your
home and auto insurance policies with
policy genius
reshop your rates and you could save up
to a thousand fifty-five dollars
head to policygenius.com to get started
right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
now let's get back to the duke so
january 19th january 94. colorado i go
i'm in boulder and
i'm doing drama i'm doing comedy and
where where back then
sorry back then there were
there was a guy named andy payton
who ran who had seven
he had 14 or 15 rooms he was brilliant
i thank him for my comedy career there's
a lot of guys i got to give thanks to
rogan stanhope but he's one of the
earlier guys
um we banged heads but he liked me
and he got a he did it right he
put together a comedy newspaper
all these comics i always complain
nobody gives me a chance i want to be a
writer okay
here's your chance you're a [ __ ]
writer write a column on comedy every
week
you write a comedy on a comic you write
a comment
uh an article about a comedy club
you write an article you know he did
this really smart
and then he would make the places that
did comedy by advertising in his
newspaper
and he would put the newspaper out once
a week it was great it was really great
i mean i did comedy after a [ __ ] uh
a line dancing class you know monday
nights was an
australian bar that only sat nine people
you know tuesday nights was a [ __ ]
uh an italian restaurant that the
the waiter was also an elvis
impersonator okay
so he would cook bring out the food as a
waiter and then while you were eating
he'd come out as elvis and he was just
400 pounds
and [ __ ] you know just the beginnings
of comedy you know
and here you are getting on stage
watching joe torre and everybody on you
know
hbo and you're like i'm [ __ ] doing
comedy in an italian restaurant for an
elvis impersonator
you know that part of comedy it's just
frustrating yeah
and even though you're doing it and
you're writing and you're doing all the
things you're supposed to be doing
it's not moving as fast as you'd like it
to be moving you know
but i was all in i was out seven nights
a week okay so there was that kind of
scene where you could actually do
seven nights a week yeah okay help
wednesdays was club
56 they gave you a free steak
that's why i hit the kid in the head
with the microphone and busted his
[ __ ] head
had one of those portable microphones he
kept flicking bottle caps at the comics
and i went up there i go the next time
you flick a bottle cap
i'm gonna [ __ ] hit you in the head
and he walked up to the stage so i just
hit him with the microphone
and i forget the headline his name right
years later i saw the headliner
and he goes you're not going to hit
somebody with the microphone tonight
so mondays is the australian bar
tuesdays was comedy works open mic
oh they had this mexican bar that was an
open mic
wednesday was club 56 thursdays was el
torito
they gave you a 25 they gave you they
gave you a 25
gift certificate and then thursday
there was something else on thursdays
and then friday and saturday you're an
open micro
you you deliver chinese food all right
so i stepped on you sorry you said uh
january 94 you just got done something
you were starting to say you just got
done doing something
no i just uh
i just moved back from new jersey and i
was getting my feet on the ground
it took me about three months to get
going and now i was going
all right like things were starting to
happen i was starting to get little
calls for little comedy gigs you know
forty dollars thirty dollars i had about
20 minutes of material
you know what happened in new york
that really sparked me was
one of the last times i went to the old
triple-n
i walked in there at two in the morning
and i saw john leguizamo
working out material for eight people
but in his mind he was at madison square
garden yeah
so for years i was complaining that
every time i got on stage there was
eight people
he made it look like madison square
garden
so that's what made me say [ __ ] new york
i could get better in colorado just as
much as in new york
save half the money and be close to my
daughter
right yeah how old your daughter at this
point
a couple years old four okay four
i came back i celebrated her fourth
birthday
that started problems with me and the
ex-wife
uh and that's what was going on i had an
apartment
i had a good job i was working for a
sports betting service
in the wintertime and then on the off
season i was delivering chinese food for
coke
and i was also selling neon for my buddy
okay you know i wasn't selling volume
anymore
because remember when i took the 10 000
value into new york
yeah i never paid that guy back
[Laughter]
so
and you were selling them at three bucks
a pop too huh something
something like man he gave me like a
thousand on the arm or something
i told him i was coming back in a week
you know
i'll see you in a week okay i didn't
come back
when i came back he had moved to a
different part of colorado it was still
close to me
so i always had the money if he needed
it but i never bumped into him so [ __ ]
him
welcome to the drug game [ __ ] yeah
right
so i wasn't selling valium anymore i
still had a line on cocaine
but what i really wanted to do was do
comedy i had it down
i could do comedy from february to
august 15th
then august 15th to february 3rd i was
going to work for a sports betting
service
where i could make up to 100 grand in
six months
and then the rest of the year just do
comedy and live off that hundred that's
yeah okay
that was the plan that was the original
plan that nobody knows about
i was very satisfied with that i was a
piece of especially back then 100
even i mean now is a lot of money but
back then i wasn't even
it wasn't even about the money it was
about
you know being close to my daughter it
was
uh and just being a human being that's
it
what i was doing for a living was not
decent
selling sports picks is not a great job
it's a lot of [ __ ] grinding it's
seven days a week
you know yeah in football season it's
saturday and sunday
college football is on saturday and pro
football's on sunday so
but i had a balance i had this great
balance it was gonna work
i would make a hundred grand they put
money away for you
whatever you put away they matched and
then they sent you a check those months
you didn't work
and then on top of that i was gonna
[ __ ] uh
deliver chinese food and sell coke and
do stand up i couldn't lose
and when i say sell coke i'm talking
about i get a call from sam tripoli he
needs a gram
and i got a call from you that you need
a grant yeah i buy an eight ball
i give used to a gram i end up getting a
gram and a half to 50 bucks
you know what i'm saying right that's
what i mean selling coke i wasn't a coke
salesman
i mean yeah you were a valiant salesman
but not a coke salesman
no no no and that wasn't really about
themselves
it was what that i sold whatever was
yeah
that's what i sold you know what i'm
saying so i don't want people to think i
was at home
now when i say coke sales i'm talking
about
for me to snort the coke i was snorting
i couldn't afford it so i would have to
wait for you
and tom segura to call me one night you
know
and say yeah we're gonna do get us two
eight balls fine
i'm gonna take a grandmother each eight
ball you know [ __ ] like that that's what
i did that was
a coke sale but everything was going
great
there was a great plan going on but
there was an undercurrent
going on and there was the undercurrent
of
the war between me and my wife
my ex-wife and her boyfriend oh she's
not by this right now okay
right by this time when i left she
already had the boyfriend
she had already moved in with him
she had already sent two guys to beat me
up and i beat up one of the guys
really she sent people to [ __ ] you up
yeah three guys
three guys drive a driver and two guys
the guy took off when he saw me in the
car
and the other guy i hit and the other
guy really threw a beat down on
and the other guy got away where where'd
they get you
in front of my house they broke my rib
damn with a [ __ ] tube
with a two by four they hit my dog with
a two by four
they [ __ ] your dog up oh they hit my
dog one time
no that dude that dude still don't eat
right
[Music]
and it wasn't because he hit me it was
for the disrespect he showed the dog
that's right that's right he still
doesn't eat right
that's right i get a thousand blessings
every day from saint lazarus
because i made sure when i kicked him in
the mouth he's not gonna eat right for
the rest of his life
he's gonna have to eat sideways you know
how i was taking his [ __ ] doing the show
sideways
that's him when i heard my dog welp
that way i heard my dog's wealth when
you hear a dog well
like that everything in my body stopped
he had to die but i'd have the balls to
kill him
so when he went down i must have kicked
him in the jaw
50 [ __ ] times and then i called the
cop
myself you did but i knew yeah oh you
know okay
because i was a i was a convicted felon
i knew that this didn't look good but
this is also an attack on
it's an assault yeah of course it's an
assault on me
but somehow because i'm a felon they're
gonna turn this around
so i called the cop i knew i thought he
was gonna [ __ ] call all the cops
and [ __ ] he's like let's put [ __ ]
cellophane in my trunk
and we'll drop him off in front of the
hospital [ __ ] him
we put him in the trunk we drove him to
the hospital with the trunk open and now
yes we did he was a cop yup you threw a
guy in the back of a trunk
with a cop this ain't the first dude you
put in the trunk
and he and he wasn't and he was not he
wasn't on duty
you drove a [ __ ] guy to the hospital
with the cop in his trunk
but he knew what was going on in my life
i had a couple cops that were my friends
and i told them what was going on in my
life and they knew what was happening
so when i [ __ ] called him he came
over and he goes [ __ ] him
he deserved what he got you know when i
told them that they
bro when a cop comes in cap in colorado
when you tell somebody that somebody hit
your dog
guns are going to come out yeah right
you know what i'm saying yeah
my dog was still walking weird i
remember him looking at my dog and
looking at the guy and kicking him again
just out of [ __ ] princesses
we took the [ __ ] guy he knew where
the cop he knew where the hospital
had cameras because he was a cop
so we dropped him off on a corner where
he couldn't be seen
we spit on him and we [ __ ] got him
so the next day they attacked me on a
saturday night
they attacked me on a saturday night and
i was supposed to get my daughter on
sunday morning
they thought i was gonna call him and
cancel i never called and canceled
uh they showed up and they were like
pale when they showed up and i didn't
say nothing
but did you know before that or was that
when you put two and two together
oh i knew it was that you did i knew i
knew exactly who it was
ain't nobody that [ __ ] dumb you know
can nobody that be that stupid she
he was that stupid she didn't tell him
the proper animal that i was
she didn't explain it to him that's what
really got me mad
about the divorce that she was there
with me in the early 80s when i carried
guns
and did things that were not supposed to
be done that were very illegal so for
her to act this way
really surprised me i'm like you know
where i'm coming from
you know what could happen here and
you're still throwing fire on this
you're still throwing alcohol on this
fire so that
before i went to new york that was why i
was so down because
they wanted me out of the kid's life i
hadn't done anything
but i'll never forget when they came to
pick her up that sunday
i put the kid in the car and i looked at
them and i told them that somebody had
attacked me
and they both turned pale i pulled up my
shirt
and i showed them the purple it was just
purple i couldn't even really move my
arm
and they were like oh my god we hope
you're okay and i'm like i'm fine
i got the guy's license he's from idaho
and the guy john her boyfriend was from
idaho i go aren't you
aren't you from idaho john and that was
the last word i said because the first
murder
the first man who speaks after that
loses i just left it at that and i
walked away from the car
and now they knew you knew yeah
it's on now it's on now we're taking it
to a different level
it's on
i wasn't wise about it i wasn't 58
i would have handled it differently
today how how would you
how well how did you handle it
by leaving okay i left by leaving
because
it kept escalating and i knew in my
world
because that was january of 94
okay by december of 94 we were at such a
war
back and forth that she just called me
out of the blue one day
and said i made up my mind you're not
getting it for christmas
now i was heartbroken you know i'm i'm
i'm paying all my money to attorneys
i suck at comedy i want it so bad you
know
i would go home at night and snort coke
and cry most people go home at nights
north coke and get their dicks up
i would go home store coke and [ __ ]
cry like a [ __ ]
you know and it was just it was just
it was just a i was just in a bad place
you know and
and i wanted to be a dad i wanted to
do comedy and i wanted to fulfill
my obligation but i could tell that they
weren't having it
so christmas of 94
i get a call like the 22nd let's just
call it the 22nd
so uh and it was her attorney
saying that she decided not to give me
the baby
i called her like a man and said you
know why are you doing this
and she gave me like a remark like
because i can
and hung up on me ryan sickler i thought
that was total disrespect first of all
it was
she she moved the guy she moved the baby
into the man's house without my consent
or knowledge
if that was to happen anywhere from
baltimore to boston
i could have shot her in the head called
the cops and the cops wouldn't have
arrested me
they were to say we understand you can't
move a child into another man's house
without permission that's just general
human decency you know what i'm saying
yeah i
i can't see your wife moving your child
into my house without us meeting no
absolutely that happened and they've
already sent
[ __ ] henchmen over to [ __ ] you up on
top of it yeah
so i had to go to war i had to
go to war with these people so
they called like on the 22nd that night
i went out
i did my comedy and i was heartbroken
and i [ __ ] the 23rd or the 24th
one of those days is maybe like a friday
or a thursday i'd have to look it up
i was so broke then i didn't even cook
in this house all i had in this house
was
fat tire beer that's all i had
fat fire beer i always ate out
i didn't even have a knife i think i had
a fork and a spoon
and maybe one knife not a steak knife
just a regular butter night i went to a
friend's house a friend of mine they're
cubans
and they were getting ready for
christmas and they're cutting [ __ ] and
they go i need a big favor i got to cut
something at the house
can i borrow your knife
and she goes take whatever one you want
and i took the biggest one
bad like those racks you know i took the
biggest one
i put it in like a bag and i put it in
my car and my job was
i was gonna drive down to where he
worked and i was just gonna cut him i
was just gonna end
his life damn that's it
that's it the day before christmas
i'm going to jail for murder i got in my
car
i drove all the way down there
i got out of my car i hid the the knife
in the jacket
and i put my arm under real close there
was kind of a security guard at the
thing
i went up to the receptionist i said
where can i find john
blah blah from this company she told me
upstairs
they didn't ask me to sign nothing or
nothing
there was a couple elevators i walked up
when i got to whatever floor i went to
his office
when i walked in the receptionist was
there and she's like can i help you and
i go
i need to speak to john such and such
and she goes oh my god if you look in
the hallway you probably just missed him
he took an early lunch today and i
remember that
i just didn't even reply to her i just
turned around
and i got on the elevator and i
went i went outside i looked around to
see if i saw him
and when i didn't see him i walked in my
car
and i just broke down and started crying
because god just saved my life she did
nobody saved two lives
i was already prepared to go to prison
and at that time the big thing was
comics or writing jokes with jay leno
and if he bought a joke you got 25 in
the mail
that was my plan so wait write jokes for
jay leno
if he's there do you do it would you
have done it at the office and
everything the setting the whole thing
you would have done it
wow yes okay how i felt that day
[Music]
i was sick and tired of feeling that way
it had been you know three years i was
feeling that way
you can't take that for so long that
that that you know
runs on you that really that really
wears on you know when i was in new york
i would send her presents
she never got the boxes she never got
the letters she never got anything i
sent
you know if i sent child support to the
house they mysteriously never got it you
know
it was just a string of [ __ ] use you
know
uh i had a fight to have her third
birthday party
at the house you know or the fourth one
whatever
so that crit and then it was weird
because
i got in the car i cried
i went home and as soon as i got home
i got a text message from my attorney
that she was gonna give me the kid
all right for christmas and
you know again i wanted to i made such a
big deal
about getting the kid for christmas i
was in no position to even throw
christmas
i didn't even know what to serve for
christmas i didn't even have a christmas
tree i had to go down to cayman and rob
a tree
like one of the ones the ones that are
outside
the lot yeah and in boulder they're nice
people they were open on christmas day
they had an envelope on the wall and it
said take a tree
leave the money in the envelope i went
in there and people had actually left
cash
i took the cash of course you did and
the tree
and i took the [ __ ] most expensive
tree they had
got me i went home
got a scottish pie here i [ __ ]
i remember i didn't have scotch tape to
put the decorations on the wall
i had to use duct tape to put the
decorations on the wall
it was such a sad christmas you know
i'm like what kind of dad am i yeah
every single gift she had was
shoplifting
there wasn't one gift that i gave her
that year
she had a room full of gifts i had
shoplifted
every one from jeffrey what's that toys
r us
why is it right yeah i love that you
remember his name
so jeffrey dollars
jeffrey [ __ ] you know
looking back it was just a [ __ ]
embarrassment you know
i ordered chinese food i had it from
like two to five on christmas day you
know like
what a [ __ ] just what a heartbreak
you know when she left men
i'm driving a car i got to close my car
i got to put a bungee on the door
oh yeah hold the door shut and and she
pulls up in a land rover or something
you know like one of those [ __ ] cars
you know
with her soon-to-be husband and it was
just a shitty
way to feel it was you know when people
hit me up and like i'm having a bad day
i i know exactly what you're like that's
what i went through for three [ __ ]
years with that
you know and then january
of 95 was when i started rocking and
rolling with comedy
i started really like one night i went
on stage
to do to do 15 and the guy that was
doing the show
took a girl outside and got his dick
sucked so he never gave me a light
oh okay yeah yeah so i ended up staying
on stage for like
43 minutes or something 34 minutes
and when he got off he's like you did 34
minutes so 43 minutes one of those
and i'm like that's it i'm calling apa
tomorrow i'm ready for the big time you
know like
i just loved comedy i was i was in a
groove
i was out every night and i got her on
sundays and wednesdays
and those were my toughest days when i
had to drop her off
so i would put a a joint in the ashtray
i would i would
drop her off and then on the walk to the
car i would
cry and i'd sit in the car and i'd cry
and i'd smoke a joint and i forced
myself to go do calmly
no matter how bad i thought right i
think that part of
how i got good at county was because of
those wednesdays and sundays
i forced myself to go to the worst two
comedy spots in the world
sunday was line dancing i had to follow
a line dancing class
and wednesday i had a [ __ ] you know
it was
it was just a bad time in my life you
know it was like
everything was [ __ ] except my comedy
career
you know and then like in
march her and i really started going at
it
like every time 95 is that what it is
okay
yeah so now she says [ __ ] you i'm gonna
start sending him
to drop the kid off to really she was
doing stuff to get under my neck sure
sure i'm trying my best
i'm like you know what i'm gonna [ __ ]
uh be a gentleman i'm gonna take the
high road
and one day he said something to me
he said uh if i was you i would think
twice before you take her to see
jurassic park or something like that
and i just spit right in his [ __ ]
face like
he he was sitting in the car
and he he like used like that you know
what do they call that white
uh white privilege yeah
yes like i don't i don't mind how you
talk to me just don't white privilege me
yeah because it's not gonna work out for
you
he white privileged me and i mean i
didn't say a word i just had like a snot
from the back of my throat
i could feel it but i had to spit and it
was like
automatic i just spit right in his face
because that's the point of my life it
was that like we're
we're going at it we're done talking
there's no reason for you to make small
talk with me you don't like me
you're trying to cut my legs out from
under me now you're telling me about a
movie
don't talk to me i just spit in his
[ __ ] face
and i still remember him looking at me
for like three minutes and the spit
rolling down his face
he didn't even have the heart to wipe it
off the [ __ ] mutt that he was you
know
i'm not mad at him no more it was a
different time
it was a different place and then
then she took me to court because he was
scared
he claimed that he was scared to come
after they send people out to [ __ ] you
up he's scared
so i had to hire a girl
to meet her
to get the kid it was a [ __ ]
nightmare then one day she decided
don't worry about it i'll meet you
because it wasn't working for her she
wasn't instigating me no more
it was perfect now i wasn't seeing her
at all she didn't want that she wanted
to get me going yeah
she wanted to round me up so it's about
april
of 95.
i [ __ ] go to the comedy works one
night
and i'm in the comedy works now
i'm not a regular but she's giving me
star spots
during the week and there was a manager
there that didn't like me
on paper he liked me but deep down
inside he didn't like me
because at one time we were neck and
neck and then i just got
way funnier than he was so he got into
the management business instead
and he told wendy that i had smacked the
girl's ass
i was supposed to open up a george lopez
that week
and wendy called me and said yeah
and wendy you know i love wendy did that
she called me up and she's like joey
you're banned i got a band you know and
i'm like listen if you call me and told
me
i robbed you or [ __ ]
[Music]
you know smack somebody or i said
something wrong on stage
i would accept it but i didn't grab no
woman's ass first of all if i'm gonna
grab some
i'm gonna grab the money i'm gonna grab
that monkey if i do grab something
i'm not gonna grab some skinny chicks
ass what do i get out of that
so you know it was like everything
like nobody everything no nothing wanted
me there in denver anymore
like now i couldn't do comedy now
like i was doing so good comedy wise now
i couldn't even do comedy anymore
and then one i'm picking up from daycare
now on wednesday
we got it this good now on wednesdays i
could pick her up at montessori
and then take it to seven
and this one day i pick her up in
montessori
and as we're going up the stairs she
goes you know she would always ask me
questions daddy
what does this mean or what does this
word mean
we were walking up the stairs and she
asked me what the word [ __ ] meant
and i go why where'd you hear that and
she goes whenever you call the house
john says that the [ __ ] is on the phone
oh
[ __ ] and what was your what was your
ex-wife's nationality by the way
she's a white child it's a white girl
okay good people good people good
family i love how people have to clarify
white people like
they're gonna be great cause so much
trouble
okay so he says that and your daughter's
asking you what that means
so now let me tell you something
about a month before this day i had a
good friend
a good friend named fred
he was a vietnam vet we had met
in 1985 the summer of 85
in boulder now it's 95 and we're dear
friends
for some reason for years i thought ed
was a medic in vietnam
ed was alert ed was one of those guys
that cut your ear off and collected it
and [ __ ]
in vietnam so i would see that at night
ed would come to watch me do comedy in
boulder and places you know like
i think there was a poetry shot that we
did comedy at
and i would meet ed and give him a
couple bugs and smoke a joint with him
so i knew what i was going through my
pain
so i was like let's just [ __ ] kill
him
you know it's like i don't know why
you're going through this
i go but do we shoot him do we bury him
he goes no we don't
we take them to chautauqua park
to the top and we rub them down with
maple syrup and we'll let the bears eat
them
they eat everything so eat his elbows
don't eat everything
you guys cover him in syrup and just tie
him up so he can't run and then the
bears are going to eat him jesus
put a gag in his mouth break his jaw so
he can't talk
and let the bears eat them i mean that's
how crazy i was oh my
that's how it goes that way yeah this is
why when i tell people i'm 58
and you have no idea
that you are i've known you for a long
time i've never heard any syrup on a
[ __ ]
i'm telling you we were gonna put syrup
on this [ __ ]
and let the bears and the tigers eat
them
that was the plan and then like that
there'd be no fingerprints there'd be no
dna
there'd be no bullets there'd be no hole
in the ground there'd be nothing
it would be so what we were gonna do is
i was
we were gonna there was a drop we were
gonna close that [ __ ] street
like ed was that crazy ed was going to
get cones
to detour him and then we were going to
jump him and [ __ ]
[ __ ] him up that was the plan all along
we were going to [ __ ] kill this
[ __ ] and if she was
and if she was with him she was going
down too
like this was this was how bad my mind
had taken this
you know i was talking about on my
podcast the other day how when your mind
takes something sometimes it just takes
it
that's why there's mental health issues
i was having
really bad mental health issues you know
stem from anger and frustration i mean
your whole background so
i'm getting ready to kill this
[ __ ]
and now i pick up my daughter and she's
telling me he's calling me a [ __ ]
he's gotta die today
like i'm like he's gonna die today i
don't even have time to call fred
i don't even have a cell phone i had a
pager you know i
there was no cell phones in 94 right
if they were i didn't have one i didn't
have that type of money no
so i me and her did what we usually do
we went to a park
you know we went to north holland north
boulder park i never forget that
and the reason why i remember north
boulder park because
there's a little uh
not a grave site like a memorial
and i remember that day it was joe
welsh's daughter
joe walsh the guitar player from the
eagles yep lived lived in boulder and
his daughter died but he lived in
boulder oh
and he put us and he made a special
little thing for her i'll never forget
this day for some reason
how it went down and i remember thinking
like wow this is crazy that
you know just somebody's gonna end up in
a [ __ ] grave here
over over an argument about a kid
you know about a child that somebody's
gonna die over this
either i'm gonna go to jail for life or
he's gonna die and i'm you know
this is not good and i remember getting
in the car
at like 6 30 and i had to meet her at
safeway
on this particular day they switched the
meat
from boulder to safeway it was outwards
a little more
and i'll never forget that with when
i was out on bail for kidnapping
they made me do community service and i
did it at the age place
and in 85 age was not a popular thing
yeah there was there was always a cop on
duty there
you know protecting the aids guys
because they would get bomb threats and
[ __ ]
so i became friends with the cop
at the aids place i would always talk to
him i would paint
walls and i was telling them what i was
going through
also with my wife
so all this is in play
i'm driving to the thing and i'm like
jackie are you sure
that he said the word [ __ ] that you
didn't hear this somewhere else
and she's like no daddy i heard it from
him i thought it was like a funny word
or something
i'll never forget pulling up at safeway
i go jackie wait here let me go talk to
john i got out of the car
and i walked up to john i go john listen
i don't want any problems
i got a five-year-old girl in the car
and she says that you use the word [ __ ]
is it true and he's like i don't know
what you're talking about
he's like thirsting how the third yeah
and i'm like dog listen [ __ ] is an east
coast word
this is boulder colorado nobody uses
this [ __ ] word
just man up and tell me you did it and
we'll move on
and he goes i feel threatened i'm going
to call the police
i go why would you feel threatened if
you didn't say it
did you say it he goes i'm going to call
the police
i go before you call the police i got
something for you
and i just smacked them open-handed with
everything i had
[ __ ] fine he's sitting in the car
no he's down he's outside he went
shopping for something
i caught him as he was bringing the
groceries back so he was putting him in
the car
and he's like where's jack where's jack
and i'm like before that i got to talk
to you
and he goes i'm going to go inside and
call the police i feel uncomfortable
it was five years of aggravation i
smacked him with an open hand to make it
even worse for him
that's the biggest insult in my world
not a punch to the face yeah slap you
there's a man
smacking him i just slapped him
open-handed
and he i slapped him so hard that he
lost his footing
he's like that's it i'm calling the
police i go before you call the cops i
got one more for you
and i got him so i got him with a double
whammy right
i'll never forget some lady was up the
corner and she yells
i'm calling the police i'm like go [ __ ]
yourself you [ __ ]
this was like five years four years
of torture that these two idiots had put
on me three and a half years
so sure enough the cops come but because
there's a guard up in the sky
guess who was the passenger cop
your buddy from safeway was no
from the eighth place no way so he he
came to me
the other cop came to me i told him my
story first he knew the story with john
he you know they put us together then
they separated us
then they decided to give me a ticket
for both of us to aspire as a summons
they didn't charge with anything
okay we both go to court
and at court i walk into court and who
is it
it's the judge that sentenced me nah now
he's
now he's a civil judge
so they turned this into like a house
thing like a domestic situation that
type thing
so i going i had always written the
judge letters
i'm a letter writer i wrote the judge a
letter when he sentenced me thanking him
to put me in jail and i wrote him
letters every month thank you
i'm the number one convict in this
facility
i eat all my corn you know whatever i
got
i got into stand-up comedy i got my ged
you know i would write him letters every
month so he knew what was going on
he was prepared already that's
interesting so when he walked in
him and my wife he had a legit backstory
he knew your backstory
that's something a judge never does
because you're just a stranger to a
judge
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with yeah joey bananas baby
so so [ __ ] uh
so [ __ ] uh the judge they're in court
yelling
they even bring they're so good who's
they who's who's yelling
my ex-wife her boyfriend they're so
desperate
they bring the arresting officer on the
kidnapping casing
to talk on their behalf i'm bad for the
community and [ __ ]
they didn't know i was talking to this
judge the whole time
me and this judge have been tight plus i
go to his brother
he's my dentist you know james like
who the [ __ ] i think you're dealing with
you know me dawg i'm a professional when
i go i go
i i'm working from every [ __ ] angle
that's sure as [ __ ] dude
the mafia is working it from every angle
so
we're in court and the judge rips up the
summons and he goes there's only one
problem here
there's a uh boulder state a boulder
county law
you can't use a racial slur in the city
limits is that right
i smacked them one block into the city
limits
so the court got thrown out of it got
thrown out of the court
and then her and him and the cop
started yelling at the judge to
reprimand me and all this [ __ ] but
i'm like i'm not having it the judge
looked at my wife
and he goes weren't you in here a couple
years ago singing his praises
now you want to come in here tell me
he's a bad guy i'll tell you what i'm
going to do
the next time you miss a visitation
i'm going to find you a thousand dollars
in throwing you in jail for contempt of
court
so she starts crying her boyfriend
starts crying
he's yelling
and now joey diaz goes to work
there was a long walk out of that
[ __ ] courtroom it was like a 100 yard
walk to the car
i didn't stop saying [ __ ] to the car
i kept walking saying tell your husband
i used to put up your ass with carrots
tell them tell them i used to i call it
kathy carrots and all this [ __ ]
i never put a carrot in her ass but i
had a [ __ ] you know
it got so bad he walked away from her
like i was saying so many things to her
like a [ __ ] smells like feet
he walked away from her that's how
embarrassing it got he was so
embarrassed
i got in my car i didn't feel too good
about what happened
and but here's the clinker but after i
smacked john
and the cops came i remember looking at
the car
and seeing my daughter and she was
crying
she was upset i saw my dad
my stepdad beat up a guy when i was six
and i was jumping up and down that was
my
you know what i'm saying that was my
word totally yes right
that was my world this little girl this
isn't her world no
so all these factors contributed i go
they're trying to put a family together
i'm just here i'm just here wasting time
even if even if i get co-parenting
whatever that's called mixed uh whatever
that's co-parenting's right split
custody
shared custody or whatever let's be
honest that's what i am what type of
what type of father what type of father
would i be
at the age of by this time it's 95
i'm 32 years old i'm like let's say i do
get
split custody what's gonna change
i'm still gonna do coke there's no woman
in this house
the only women that come here to suck my
dick they're terrible women they just do
blow my blow and do
you know there's no food i don't cook i
have no
foundation i don't go to church i have
nothing
that requires me now i don't even have a
comedy club
i met a girl in seattle i met a girl in
michigan she said she was moving to
seattle
i prayed on it for about a month and i
thought about it
this was going to end this thing in
boulder was going to end
there was three ways this is gonna end
me being dead me going to jail
him dying or both of them dying
and then my daughter has to be raised
without a parent right
i put in the lord's hands and i said you
know what
i'm gonna do an extended triple run i
took a two month triple run
i paid my rent off yeah you did what all
the pacific northwest and [ __ ]
yeah the potato one to run one potato
run two
the whole thing and i um
said i'm gonna put it in god's hands and
i'm gonna be a comedian and i'm gonna
let
i'm gonna make her proud of me i'm gonna
prove
whatever they told her wrong of me
and then i'll be her father
well 30 years later i proved her wrong
but i still don't have them
but god drew me the 18.
god threw me another little girl that
fills the void
now i have a real family i act like a
real man i'm not a savage anymore
and that's it for today so now we're in
june
of 95. i'm writing it down june 95.
all right joey diaz i [ __ ] love you
what an episode
again what an episode um one more time
promote everything the patreon all that
stuff again please
patreon and uncle vinnie's in point
pleasant the whole month
month of march on wednesday nights
all right bro 37 37 tickets
you're in no danger getting covered he
spaces it out byob
it's a great club i love dino and that's
the only place i'm performing at right
now in jersey
that's awesome brother well thank you
for making time for this and just
i just thank you for having me i love
you i miss you
oh i miss you i miss you like hell we'll
pick up whenever we do next time
june of 1995. as always ryan sickler
on all social media ryan sickler.com
we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you